Okay.
Alright.
This is gonna be interesting.
Also, hello everyone!
Hello, Lieutenant, Deadpool, Sayori, Maple, Skulltaker, Dylan...
Oh, who else?
Who else?
I think Renner.
Alright, hey guys.
Okay.
This is gonna be an interesting chat, because I've never played Portal before.
Oh, my god!
Esini.
Thank you so much for the- for the- Oh shit!
Oh, I knew I forgot something.
I forgot to add my alert box!
Look, I told you this is Scuffed, okay?!
Alright, let me replay this.
I forgot about my alert box!
I'm like, I must be missing something here, right?
I'm missing something, right?
And it's my alert box?!
Woo!
Can we get some Berk Nights, real quick?
For, um, Esini.
For the 55 007 king.
The tier 1 sub for 5 months.
Also, break nights for Lieutenant too.
Holy shit, okay, I don't know if I should play music.
Should I play music in the background?
Um... for this chat?
Cause, uh...
Uh, this is what we hear.
Like, damn.
Do I play music in the background?
I don't know if it'll like, fuck up the immersion or whatever.
Alright, alright, alright.
New game.
Chapter 1.
Alright, I've never played Portal before, so...
Portal soundtrack kinda slaps?
Alright, alright.
Alright guys, I guess you can backseat game.
Uh, cause I'll be so fucking embarrassed.
Trying to figure shit out.
And then I'll be like, oh I can play right now?
How do I pick shit up?
Oh.
Can I pick shit up?
Oh shit, I can walk.
Okay, I can jump.
Alright.
I'm learning?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Rancid can we...
Can we socialize with the tier 1 19 ones?
Okay, I'm just listening real quick.
Can we get some break?
Can I do a quick for Rancid?
Let's listen to some class.
Am I zoomed in?
Oh shit, I got pfft!
Why is my game so zoomed in?
I'm so scuffed.
I was like, oh my god.
Why is this so zoomed in?
Okay, that makes sense.
I was like, damn, what the fuck is wrong with my game?
What the fuck?
Alright, everything is...
Alright, alright, alright.
Here we go.
Professional streamer.
What?
Is there subtitles?
Hello, Zark!
Oh, is the chat going to be full of intervention?
Oh shit, is that me?
Okay.
I got this chat.
I got this.
Can I run?
Oh, is this the companion queue?
Oh.
Excuse me.
Excuse me?
Are you kidding me?
Okay, there, there.
Apparently I am not very good at physics.
Alright, first puzzle.
First puzzle is done.
We did it.
First puzzle.
I'm so smart.
I passed level one.
This is so sad.
Yes, please clap for me.
Oh my god, you're so smart.
Doki, you're so fucking smart.
Wow.
You did it.
Thank you, thank you guys.
I think I know.
I know, I'm very smart.
I'm very smart.
God, it's so embarrassing.
Place the weighted storage cube on the 1500 megawatt Aperture Science Heavy Duty Super Colliding Super Button.
You put that cube...
I know, right?
Shit.
Who else could do that?
Not your... only me.
Oh, okay, here.
Oh.
Oh, what?
What?
Let me in!
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Is this timed?
It's timed, right?
Oh, gotcha.
Perfect.
Please move quickly to the chamber lock.
As the effects of prolonged exposure to the ground and... Is this the user one brings us?
Okay, it's timed.
Okay, okay.
I'm slowly learning.
I'm slowly learning the mechanics.
It has to defy physics and force the camp through...
I didn't... I thought it was a glitch, okay?
I didn't...
I thought it was a glitch.
Is there bee hopping here?
I'm bee hopping.
Very slowly, very slowly.
Hey, Tsuna!
I'm trying to learn right now.
It's a...
It's like...
It's technically an FPS...
Oh, shit, really?
It's not part of any test protocol, but it should already be a guide.
Oh, my god!
I actually don't know how to bee hop.
I...
Oh, you're enjoying Portal?
I did!
I got past level one!
It's apparently very hard, from what my chat told me.
Level one is very...
It's a very hard game.
Oh!
Okay, I got the portal done.
No, I've never played Half-Life.
I think I... I've not played a lot of games.
Only till I joke and pass Level...
This game will make you grow wrinkles.
Oh, my god.
I'm so sorry.
Roy!
Thanks so much for the tier three!
Eight months!
Can I get some Park Night's real quick for Roy?
Oh, my god!
Atlas!
Thank you!
Thank you for the...
I'm sorry.
I think... I...
I...
I don't know if I can help you with that.
I don't know if that will help, but thank you, Atlas!
For the $50!
Thank you so much!
Hello, Michael!
By the way, I saw what you meant when Peter said, thank you for hours.
I wanted to say that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
I'm so fucking smart.
How do I...
Oh, my god!
I'm so smart!
Okay, to be fair, I just...
To be honest, I just...
Spammed... I just spammed shots until it worked.
I wasn't...
I don't know how I did it, but I did it.
Thank you again, Roy, for the fucking tier three.
So, it's crazy!
And also the $50!
Dude, I didn't even think about where to shoot it.
It just happened naturally.
You're doing so well.
What's this?
What is this?
Did it work?
Oh!
I thought this was it!
I thought this was the thing!
Oh, my god!
I'm so fucking stupid!
Please.
You broke so much!
This solid puzzle!
I did it!
Hey, Fez!
Okay.
Is this still level one?
I can't even tell.
I think right click and left click do a different portal.
Oh, I just been spamming left click.
Until it works.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't
know what I'm doing.
Oh, my god!
God, I'm so fucking smart.
Okay, where's the other one, though?
Is it this?
Oh, my god!
Holy shit!
I'm so sorry!
This is really long level one.
So you're gonna get stuck here only on level one.
Good job.
Oh, good job!
She said good job!
I'm big green.
I am big green.
Huh?
Where the fuck am I?
What?
What happened?
I don't even know what happened!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck happened?
Hahaha!
If I do, you gonna require his brain power.
I see this keep going so long.
What is this?
Oh!
Hahaha!
Okay, okay, okay, look...
Blood safety is one of many enrichment center goals.
The Aperture Science High Energy Pallet, seen to the left of the chamber, can and has caused prominent disabilities such as...
Okay, look...
Blood safety is one of many enrichment center goals.
The Aperture Science High Energy Pallet, seen to the left of the chamber, can and has caused prominent disabilities such as...
Oh my god, I did it.
First try, first try.
Also, thank you so much for the follow, Dargo!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a, have a butter, thank you so much!
Okay, wait, have a butter, yeah.
Look, look, look, first try, first try, first try.
Never died once, never died, never died.
Oh, Fluffy, thank you so much for the five bits!
Thank you, thank you, I really do appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Is that, is that five bits for my...
No deaths run?
Thank you, thank you, I know.
Haven't died yet.
I'm so fucking smart.
I'm pretty good, I'm pretty good at this game, yeah, see?
Desi thinks so.
I'm pretty fucking good.
Warning devices are required on all mobile equipment.
However, alarms and flashing hazard lights have been found to agitate the High Energy Pallet, and have therefore been disabled for your safety.
What, what is this?
Oh.
Oh shi-!
Interceptor signs on stationary scaffold.
What's going on?
Oh!
Okay.
She's, she's lost out there prog- what?
Oh, okay, it moves.
Damn, look at that, first try.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm getting this, I'm getting this.
My brain is slowly expanding.
It is getting bigger and bigger.
Oh shit, oh yeah guys, you saw, I saw what happened on Twitter for me, right?
Like, I was supposed to stream at 10, and then like, and then all the guru shit that happened.
Basically, okay, so...
Please note that we have added a consequence for failure.
Wait, let me get here.
I need to listen.
Any contact with the chamber floor will result in an unsatisfactory mark on your official testing record, followed by death.
Good luck.
Okay, so I was supposed to stream.
Um...
Are you sure you felt geometry?
Oh my god.
I was about to jump down.
Okay, so what happened was that basically the whole guru shit, apparently, apparently...
Is this what I'm supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do?
Is this, is this it?
Okay, so apparently, okay, so apparently guru accidentally, uh, she didn't know and she fucking...
Wait, what?
Where do I...
Where do I take this?
Where, where is it going?
Where is it going?
Where is this going?
Like this?
Where...
Where are you going?
Wait, did I do it?
Oh no, wait, wait, no.
Not yet.
Wait.
What is this?
Where are you?
Oh.
I...
Oh yeah, no, the emote got removed, basically.
But I had to like, deal with all that shit earlier today.
I...
What?
Wait, what?
Okay, so basically, guru asked, uh...
Uh, used emotes that were from an emote artist that were, that was tracing emotes.
So I had to like...
I had...
What the fuck?
I'm so fucking confused.
So...
So I had to like, uh...
I had, I made like a whole social media post about it.
And then she got it removed in an hour after that.
Which was pretty nice.
Cause usually like, you know, people don't react that fast and stuff.
So like my, um...
I like, like...
I like contacted my friend that got her emotes traced by that person.
So, guru was using those emotes for...
What the fuck am I doing?
Where, where is it?
Oh my god, can I...
Can I go here?
Where is this?
Okay.
Oh!
Look, I saw you go there!
Okay.
I'm so confused.
I'm so confused, chat!
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
No, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Okay, okay.
Uh...
Wait, I got this.
I, I swear.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hey, Shijin!
I'm gonna bring her a smile.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, okay, wait.
Okay.
Like, no, no.
Oh!
Oh, I know!
I, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know this.
I know this.
It's right here.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Oh my god, look, look, look at those!
Oh, I missed.
I missed!
I fucking missed!
I got it.
First try!
Oh, I forgot about the death ball.
At the end, it comes through the orange and it bounces.
Yeah, I didn't even get to read it, Lieutenant!
I didn't even get to read it!
I might have missed though.
I might have missed the, missed the first time.
Look.
Alright, first try, first try.
Never missed.
Never missed once.
Look at that.
That, my brain, my brain is so fucking big.
This is so sad.
This is so fucking sad.
Okay, but yeah, it was like a huge mess.
It was such a huge mess with the Gura thing.
And then now everyone's like trying to, everyone's trying to, trying to like get in on the, on the whole like, now that Gura has like new emote slots and stuff, every, all the emote artists are trying to get in on it and being like, I'm so sorry about,
about the whole, I saw like two emote artists doing sketches.
I don't know if he was one of them.
But then there was another one.
Uh, there was another emote artist doing sketches, hoping to get picked by Gura now.
Okay, before I, every time I take away a slice of the cake.
It's okay.
The cake's a lie anyway.
I don't need cake.
Oh.
Oh, I was like, this is easy.
I can just take it over there.
Okay.
Look at this.
Bam.
The Enrichment Center apologizes for this clear mess.
Oh, this is easy.
Boom.
Why the fuck is this easier?
Why was this easier than the last level?
What the fuck?
You remained resolute and resourceful in an atmosphere of extreme pessimism.
How the fuck was this easier?
That's not fair.
Okay.
But yeah, it was, uh, it was pretty chaotic.
I had to.
I'm surprised.
I'm, I'm surprised.
I'm surprised that no one like even like, uh, uh, mentioned about like girls traced emotes there.
Cause I, when I saw it, I was like, wait a minute.
Weren't those the traced emotes from that artist earlier?
And then, and then I was like, what the?
It's like, yeah, it's girls' art.
Yeah.
That's a big, a big opportunity.
Uh, going crazy too.
Going crazy about what?
Yeah.
This is very much about what the fuck did you say to me?
Um, but yeah.
Hello again.
I just got a call from a friend.
I couldn't believe that no one noticed it and I was the only one that like talked about it.
What are he, uh, where he notes in the Q and a, what is girl?
Grace the, the, the hollow live, uh, shark girl, uh, in the English, in the English community.
And like, what the fuck am I supposed to do here?
Oh, that's what it's supposed to do.
That's.
That's what I'm supposed to do.
Okay.
Where's the portal?
Oh!
Did I do it?
Is this the other side?
No, this is not the other side!
Oh yeah, yeah, and then Agura's emotes...
New emotes were traced from other Twitch emote artists.
And she didn't know.
So then I made a...
Phone died.
Yeah, so no one...
What the fuck?
Wait!
How?
How did I do this?
What?
Wait!
How did I...
Okay, I passed the level.
I don't even need a no.
I don't even need a no!
I just did it!
I don't know how the fuck I did this.
Here?
I just almost barked.
Hit empty.
Okay, this is momentum.
Momentum.
The function of mass and velocity is conserved between portals.
In layman's terms, speedy things come out.
You launch yourself across the...
Wait, where's the door?
Wait.
Where is it?
Oh.
Oh my god, I did it!
I did it!
I think that's how portal works.
Each time you go through, you add mass to one and take it away from the other.
So you keep falling.
Eventually, you'll make a black hole.
Oh!
I...
I'm pretending to understand you, but...
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best, chat.
I'm trying...
Also, hi.
Hi, Gold.
I'm good.
I'm just...
How hard do you want me to control backseating?
Um...
I think, like, even when I read the backseating comments...
...to always provide useful advice.
Like, is she giving me good advice?
Because I've not been listening.
I've not been listening at all, honestly.
But, like, I feel like even if people try to give me backseating gaming advice, I still don't understand.
I still wouldn't understand.
Because I remember Major was trying to...
I think it was Major was trying to explain to me something.
Or Lieutenant.
And I read it, and I was like, what the fuck are they trying to explain?
What are they talking about?
I don't think I'll understand even...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
We don't...
Oh.
Oh, water bad.
What?
Water bad.
But you...
The Enrichment Center promises to always provide a safe testing environment.
In dangerous testing environments, the Enrichment Center promises to always provide useful advice.
For instance, the floor here will kill you.
Try to avoid it.
What?
For your reference, it takes people an average two hours and three minutes to compete their game on their first try.
Oh.
But I'm not...
I ain't like other people.
I'm not average.
What is this?
Oh, it's this.
I'm just built different.
I'm just built...
Oh, no!
No!
Oh, my God.
I'm just built...
You are built different now.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Have a...
Have a good one.
Thank you so much.
I'm just built different.
Where was I supposed to go?
Did I do it right?
Oh I did it!
Oh no!
I thought I was clear.
I thought I was clear after that.
Sorry, we haven't died yet.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Okay, alright.
We got it.
Where am I supposed to go?
Where?
What the?
Dookie touched the bat.
Why?
I'm gonna post one of these bat voice every time you get caught.
Oh my god!
Did I touch the gun?
Oh!
I was like, what do I do?
Also, I'm just... thank you so much for the 800 vids.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Sorry!
Thank you for the five gifted subs!
Holy shit!
Thank you!
I have some clots, some clots.
Woo!
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, can we get some Fortnite real quick?
Can we get some Fortnite real quick?
Sorry, thank you so much.
Okay.
Alright, what do I do now?
What is this?
Excuse me?
How do I get there?
How do I?
Oh!
Wait, no, no, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I already did the portal layer.
Okay, I don't need to click it.
I don't need to click it.
Okay, okay.
We got this.
Dude, my brain is expanding.
My brain is expanding.
Look at that.
First try.
First fucking try.
No streamer can do first tries like me.
But, I'm glad you- I'm glad like my LapTater.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
This is not a two-hour game.
This is not- This cannot be a two-hour and thirty.
I refuse to play Fortnite.
I can't believe this is a 2 hour 30 minute game.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Boom, first try.
Oh.
Okay, that's not it.
That has not it.
Wait, no!
I did it!
Look at that.
Boom!
I did it!
Wait.
Did I... did I fuck up?
Wait, wait, wait.
Where do I go?
Oh, okay!
Look at that.
Boom.
I did it.
Oh my god, tater!
Oh my god, sorry!
Okay, I said it wrong.
Sorry, thank you so much for the gift and stuff to tater!
Thank you, thank you!
Can we get some Fortnite drill?
Oh my gosh, how can I clap now?
Can we get some Fortnite drill quick?
To tazar for gifting us stuff to tater.
I really do appreciate it, guys.
I really do appreciate it.
I checked it at 2.7 hours.
Okay.
Alright.
So 2.7 hours is the speedrun, right?
It's the speedrun.
And now... don't worry.
Okay, okay.
What the fuck?
Where does this... what does this open?
Oh...
How do I get this?
How...
Where is it?
Did I fuck up?
What?
I'm so confused!
What did she do?
It doesn't even...
This is what she did.
Oh...
Wait... but why?
Wait... where is it?
How do I...
Where the fuck is the queue?
Where is it?
She's just stupid!
Oh my god!
I'm so fucking smart!
Look at that shit!
I didn't need your help anyway!
Boom!
Wheeeee!
I did it!
Let's try it.
What do you mean I'm not stupid?
I'm not stupid!
I swear!
I'm just built different!
I'm just built different, chat!
I'm just built... exactly!
I'm just built different!
Some people are just built different!
Now that you are in control of both portals, this next test could take a very, very long time.
If you become lightheaded from thirst, feel free to pass out.
Okay.
See, she said it usually takes a long time, so it's fine.
You have a brain the size of Mars.
It was really a one brain cell!
Yeah, it's... I'm just built different!
Look at that!
She said it'll take a long time, so that's okay.
It's supposed to take a long time.
Should I do this?
Look at that.
I'll turn up as a tourist group!
Oh, no!
It's a place full of arid stems!
Where the fuck is this?
Where's the cube?
Oh, there's a cube.
Wait, how do I get the cube?
Oh, wait, that is not the right way to aim.
Is it this?
Okay...
Where the fuck...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got this.
Hmm?
Ah, shit, look at that!
Ringle burr.
Okay, okay, okay.
I thought you were gonna...
Yeah, exactly!
What do you mean?
I didn't miss!
I don't know what you're talking about.
You think I missed shots?
That was a headshot right there.
How do I get over there?
Oh my gosh, is this...
Wait, wait, wait.
I've got this.
I know what to do.
Okay.
Maybe... maybe I don't know what to...
Wait.
I know what to do.
Boom!
Look at that.
First try.
Why make it so...
What do you mean?
Where's my other...
Okay, okay.
This is our eighth segment.
Look at that.
See?
This is gonna get to the last one.
We're almost...
We're like, he's the new tech.
Okay.
Where do we go after that?
Where's the other one?
For
your own safety, do not destroy vital testing apparatus.
Wait.
Where's the other one?
I...
What?
Oh!
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Where's the other...
Cube?
Where's...
Oh!
Okay, how do I get out of here though?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Left click.
Oh my...
Fucking...
Okay.
Sometimes you just build different.
There you go.
I'm just built different.
Look at that.
Wait, wait.
This is the entrance way.
I walked the wrong way.
I'm just built different.
I'm sorry.
Just went backwards.
There was an open door.
There was an open...
You go...
Everyone goes through open doors.
Sorry for my success.
Okay.
Okay, chat.
I swear, is this still level one?
Is this still fucking level one?
This cannot still be level one.
All subjects intending to handle high energy gamma leaking portal to...
...technology must be informed that they may be informed of...
...assetable regulatory compliance issues.
What's that?
No further compliance information is required or will be provided.
And you are an excellent test subject.
See?
She said I'm excellent.
She said I'm excellent, chat.
Dougie's 90% brain.
If the elevator door is open, there's no...
...to go through the door.
Everyone goes...
Exactly!
Everyone goes through open doors.
What?
You go through the closed door?
Okay.
Where the fuck am I?
Huh?
Okay, okay.
That's not- That's clearly not it!
This is fluent in sarcasm, by the way.
Well, maybe to you, but to me, she- I'm like her favorite test subject.
I'm her favorite.
Okay, maybe just for fun, you should put a portal on the ceiling for it and move at it.
At max speed?
I can't even run!
What do you mean?
This is the fastest I go!
Oh, you mean bunny hop?
Do I bunny hop?
Oh, that didn't work.
I don't know if I'm doing it right.
Here?
Oh, that was not it!
That was not it.
Okay.
This?
That's not max speed!
What do I do?
It'll work one day.
Okay, I give up.
Okay, this isn't clear enough.
It's clearly not this.
Oh, wait!
Is it?
Okay, the f***ing f***!
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Is it like this?
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
I know, I know, I know, I know.
My brain, my brain.
Brain expanding.
How did I f*** that up?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I...
I don't know!
Oh, I can!
I know, I know, I know, I know!
I know, I know, I know, I know.
Okay, no, I don't.
I don't know.
You gotta line him up better?
How?
How do I...
How do I line this up better?
Like this?
Uh -oh.
I'll get it right...
Oh f***!
Okay.
Okay, geometry is not my...
my strong geometry.
I'm not good at geometry.
I'm sorry.
Is this...
Is this it?
I got this.
I got...
Oh my god.
I almost got it.
He got it!
He got it.
I'm struggling.
I don't know what I'm...
Okay, now they're both up top.
Don't worry.
One day we'll get there.
One day.
Two... This is not a speedrun.
Just remember, two hours...
is the... is the speedrun time.
That's the speedrun.
Two hours is the speedrun.
We're doing the average gameplay.
The average run of the mill.
Oh!
Oh I did it.
I thought I did it.
I was so happy.
Please!
I'm...
Why is this so hard?
Oh my god!
This is...
Wait, you need to put the port at the bottom and one in the ceiling?
Is it for Cress?
Oh!
Oh my god!
How did I still fuck that up?
How did I manage to fuck that up?
Oh my god!
How did I still fuck that up?
How?
Please.
That's a clean break.
Where does this even take me?
Oh!
It's this door.
Okay, I already forgot what door was what.
How long do you think we've been here?
Three hours!
No, actually five hours.
Five hours.
I'm being...
Oh.
Well then.
Six hours.
It is always getting the portal on the floor.
It's to aim under you as you fall.
Also, alright, just flip me off.
It's for gold?
Alright, here you go, gold.
This is for you.
I'm bee hopping.
Okay.
This goes up and down.
Hey, twins!
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is not supposed to be there.
Okay.
Where is this supposed to go?
It is supposed to go there.
Okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
Oh, no no no.
No no no no no.
No no no no no no no no no NO!
NO!
Don't!
Oh, he was going to heaven.
He saw me.
Okay, okay.
I got this.
Boom.
And then BAM.
And then...
Boom.
Oh, wait wait wait.
I fucked up.
Oh wait.
Wait wait wait.
Wait wait I fucked up.
Boom.
Wait.
Boom?
Where does it go?
What?
Is this portal 2?
Yeah.
No, this is portal 1.
BOOM!
Wait!
No!
Please.
Wrong boom.
I have to go all the way back?
Wait wait wait.
I need this for...
For that.
Okay.
Boom.
Okay okay okay.
Please do not have a death counter for me.
Because you guys don't even remember how many times I've died.
So technically I've never died.
Technically I've never died chat.
Because you guys don't even remember.
So no death counter for you.
Okay.
Boom.
Michael uses portals to cross faster.
Wait no.
But how can I use portals if I'm using portals for the boom?
How can I use portals if I'm using portals for the boom?
That doesn't make sense.
I already put the orange, so I just need the blue, right?
No no.
It's zero.
Zero times.
Watch this.
That's right.
God!
So sweet.
And he's on a cute track.
Okay, wait, where do I go?
Oh, you send your previous body to...
Oh!
Look at that.
First try, zero deaths.
Zero deaths, zero deaths.
No one have a counter, so technically I've never died, right?
This is so pathetic.
Fucking children get finished with games.
I hate doing three-tailed during bird outs in your mind.
You're not dying.
Out of territory, she's moving into a new...
Exactly, exactly, I'm not dying.
I've technically never died.
Did I do it?
Did I cross?
Dermatocarp, thank you so much for the follow.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Where's my hands?
Have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, where's my butt heart?
Where's my hands?
Oh, there it is.
Have a butt heart.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Wait, how long is this stream?
It's been 30 minutes.
We've only been streaming for 30 minutes.
Isn't that crazy?
And we're like 80% done of this...
No, no, 30 minutes.
I had to bed, night chat, and also thanks for the...
Alright, good night.
Good night, Deadpool.
Thank you again for hanging out with us.
I really do appreciate it.
We have a good rest of the night.
Where the fuck am I?
30 minutes.
Oh...
Oh, I can go...
What?
Huh?
I can...
Shijin...
Thank you so much for the tier one... for two months.
Thank you, Shijin.
Thank you.
Oh, can we get some..?
Oh my gosh, one hand and clap.
Can we get some break nights real quick for Shijin?
Are the tier ones still for two months?
Alright.
I got this.
Wait, I need to look at this for a sec.
No!
Wait!
I did it.
Hi Marshall!
I'm proving to everyone that I too can use... wait.
Where's the exit?
No, no, no.
It's this one.
This one.
So it shows that children under the age of 13 complete portal within hours on their first...
within four hours of their first... of their first... of their first...
That's good!
Cause I'm only on my first 30 minutes.
I've only been playing this game for 30 minutes.
Don't mind the timer.
Twitch is bugged right now.
I've only been playing Portal for 30 minutes chat.
I've only been playing Portal for 30 minutes.
So everyone's lying to you.
It doesn't say 30 minutes.
Wait, is this another area?
Oh, this is another area!
Where the fuck is this?
Huh?
Oh, do I make the falling thing?
Oh my.
Am I trapped?
What is this?
Six take it...
Oh!
Boom!
Oh, it didn't work.
It didn't work.
I should start playing machine practice.
I forgot everything.
I actually never...
Okay.
Huh?
Oh, I'm here.
Okay.
Is this right?
Wait, I had it lined up?
What?
Huh?
Certain objects may be vital to your success.
Do not destroy testing applications.
No!
I got this!
Wait, what is this?
Oh, I cannot use that.
Maybe my jump?
No.
Wait.
Huh?
I say, you are the best.
I wish I could be more active, but glad to see you are my footing.
Huh?
Oh, Pia-san!
Thank you for the tier one for 29 months!
Can we get some Fortnite?
You will play for Pia-san!
Thank you!
Yes, I got my footing.
I got this!
This is the first try.
I've only been playing this game for 30 minutes.
30 minutes!
It's only been 30 minutes and I'm already 90% done with this game.
Wait, no... no...
Do I jump like this?
Wait!
Oh...
Wait, wait, wait, wait...
Wait, wait, wait... 30 minutes!
30... I've only been playing this game for 30 minutes, chat!
It's only been 30 minutes!
Wait, wait, I got this, I got this.
Do I... I know, I know, I can b-hop.
I b-hop here, right?
Okay, no, that's not it.
Maybe... maybe if I keep doing it...
Maybe if I keep doing it...
Boom!
Check everywhere?
Wait, can I go backwards?
Wait!
Oh no, I'm trapped.
I'm b-hopping!
Yes, yes, this is b-hop!
I'm fucking doing... I play FPS games.
I know how to b-hop!
Where else can I...
Where...
Where else?
Wait, wait a minute!
Wait a minute!
I got this!
Okay, no, I don't... no, I thought... I thought... I thought I got it.
I thought I... I thought I... I got it.
Wait!
Oh, is it here?
Wait, wait, there's instructions!
There's inst... Oh, there's inst... Wait!
I got it!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Okay, no, wait...
Wait...
Wait, what?
Go...
How do I put it here?
How do I...
How?
Please!
You wanna play support on the...
Okay, okay, okay.
Boom!
Oh,
my brain!
My brain is expanding!
Watch!
Boom!
Oh, my god!
What did I miss?
I actually missed!
I didn't notice!
I'm not even on that top 500 now!
Look, I got top 500 not for my brain, okay?
It was not for my brain.
It was not for my brain, okay?
Wait, wait!
Okay, okay.
Has returned as to your house.
Hello, torture!
Okay, okay, wait.
I need to line this up.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got it, I got it.
I got this, I got this.
Boom!
And it...
Okay, okay, I got this.
I got this.
I...
How did I not jump?
How you do this?
It's easy.
Even though this is in 30 minutes.
We won't even play for...
How...
How do I miss the jump?
How do I miss the jump 20 times?
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a...
Have a blood heart.
Oh, shit.
Where's my heart?
Have a blood heart.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Okay, okay.
Just let yourself fall through it.
Okay.
Have a breath.
I still fucked that up.
How?
Call 11, you're watching Outwanderer's supposed to be a class.
Okay.
Alright.
Ow!
Okay.
Fall through.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
Okay.
Now, I'm going to jump.
Alright, first try.
First try.
I got it, I got it.
First try!
It's never fucked up before.
Did it need your help?
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, it goes there.
First try.
Okay.
Boom, boom.
Boom.
How do I... I... Boom?
Oh!
Boom!
I got this.
I just...
Okay,
I just need to fall through like this.
And then...
And I just gotta keep falling through, right?
Right?
Oh my god!
I was right!
Holy shit!
Wait, shit, I'm doing this rainbow so far that she can only see through the boom.
Like, I did it!
I did it!
I'm learning!
I'm learning.
My algorithm's getting better, chat.
Are you still... Yeah, we're still doing horror games.
We're so close.
We're like... We're like 20-something, I think.
I think I can't...
I'm doing math.
I'm doing math, dude.
I'm... I'm... I'm freaking out math right now.
I can barely fucking boom correctly.
For one time I spent 50 minutes on a puzzle and two odd dudes saw I was moving the box lately.
She did it.
It's 200 cells.
200 cells, and then we'll have a scary game.
It's not scary.
Are you talking?
Okay.
It goes boom, boom, boom.
So, boom, boom.
Boom.
And then...
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Oh, wait.
Boom.
Boom?
Where is this?
Wait, how do I get it straight?
I'm gonna say those boots are gonna need a boom.
I'll let you have my brain cell.
Thank you, Lieutenant.
I need every brain cell I can get right now.
Wait, where does this go?
It goes...
Alright, I'm trying to angle this.
Okay, it's here.
This is...
This is the thing.
Right here.
Boom.
Boom, boom, boom.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Can I put portal here?
No, I cannot.
Where the fuck do I...
Where...
How does it go here?
What the fuck?
My brain!
My brain expanding!
Wait, where did it go?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
It goes...
Boom, boom.
Right?
No, no, it's angled.
It's angled.
The screen is like...
I'm so confused.
Wait.
What?
How does this... Is this geometry?
Do I need to know geometry for this chat?
Do I...
What?
How did it go from here?
I'm so confused.
Wait, I think I almost got it!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait, how am I... how is this working?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, wait.
Here, and then curve, and then goes back to me, and then...
No, that's not it, that's not it.
That's not it, I haven't seen...
Here?
No, wait, no.
Wait, why is this here?
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, oh.
Okay, geometry, I just need to learn geometry.
I just need to learn geometry chat.
I... Geometry?
Yeah?
Wait!
Oh no, that's not...
Oh, I do, I do.
It's like waiting for the pause to hit the corner.
On the TV screen from this game, it makes your brain the opposite of smooth.
And a little... okay.
Physics, okay, I just need to learn geometry and physics chat.
I got this, it's not like I almost fell geometry.
I just...
Wait, wait, is this it?
No.
Wait, no.
Okay.
Here?
Is this...
Is it angled correctly?
I'm just gonna wait until it's angled and equals angle... angles out.
Okay, okay, Pythagoras theorem.
I just need the Pythagorean theorem, right?
Okay, is this angled now?
Oh, no, it's not.
Here?
Oh, I'm learning geometry.
Oh, my god, did I do it?
Wait, where did it go?
Is it here?
Am I learning it?
Where does my thing go?
Here?
Oh!
Oh, what?
I'm learning...
I'm just going there.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, where is it?
Oh, wait, no, that's not it.
That's not it.
That was not...
Is it here?
I'm just doing it until it works, chat.
I'll get there.
I'll get there very slowly.
Okay, that's not it.
Huh?
I really love her lizard.
She's still on freeze.
Okay, that... wait, is it this?
No, it's going down.
It's going...
I don't know.
Please!
How do I do this?
Is it here?
I'm gonna watch the whole frame.
I'm so confused, chat.
Is this it?
Wait, the ball is supposed to go...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait!
This
is it?
Wait.
No?
No.
Also, thank you so much for the follow, check.
Thank you.
Thank you for the follow.
Here's the butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Here?
I
did it!
Oh, I'm so sorry!
Oh, my God!
I'm so fucking sorry!
God!
I didn't need any of your help.
Look at that shit!
How do I get out of here?
Wait, how do I get out?
How do I...
How do I get out?
Wait.
How do I get out of here?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, I got this, I got this.
I land here, right?
And then, oh, the portal doesn't work there.
Oh!
I know, I know, I know.
Boom!
Oh.
Wait.
And then...
And...
I can't...
I'll get there.
I'll...
You're overthinking this.
Okay, I'm overthinking this.
It's simple.
It's simple geometry.
It's simple geometry chat.
She didn't get there.
Okay.
Oh!
Simple geometry.
I passed math.
I got an A plus in geometry.
Look at that.
Okay.
And then...
Yeah.
We did it.
I did it.
I did it, chat.
Wait, oh, I thought I was on this.
No, you're dead.
Look at that.
30 minutes.
This is only...
Wait, what?
Oh!
It's okay.
Don't do this.
Fuck!
I thought it...
I thought it wasn't moving.
So dumb.
Pound it on!
Oh!
Thank you so much for the one-bit hyper.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
I got this.
I...
Okay.
Did you do...
Look.
Look, chat.
Right?
Oh!
Right.
And then...
Right?
Oh!
I just need to wait for this.
Okay.
I got...
Oh!
I actually scared myself there.
Look, that's me.
That's me!
Okay, now I just gotta wait for this.
Look at that.
God.
Only 35 minutes have passed since I started this game.
This is like a speedrun game.
I'm gonna run like a huge speedrun right here.
This is a speedrun record.
Right here.
Right now.
Wait.
Where is my portal?
What did I use?
Wait.
What color?
Guys!
What color was the portal?
What color was it?
I don't remember.
I...
I don't wanna wait.
I need to chat.
What color was it, guys?
Please.
I'm streaming this game for you.
It's not orange.
Oh my gosh!
It was orange!
It was orange.
Oh, I can't believe that.
Oh!
What?
I could have done that.
Okay.
Alright.
What do I have to do?
Never trust us!
Do I go up?
Up?
Up.
What does this do?
What is that?
Oh!
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
I do...
uppies.
Wait.
Uppie?
Where's the ray?
Go down?
Yeah.
Oh!
What?
Where is it?
Does this open this?
What do you open?
Open!
Oh, you have to go to the other side!
You have to go to the fucking other side.
Oh my god.
We gotta time this.
I need to keep pressing this so I...
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Please, please, please, please!
No!
Oh!
Are you g- Oh my god.
Okay, I gotta time this.
I need to time this perfectly.
Wait, where is it?
No!
Please!
Oh.
I got it.
I'm so lucky.
I did it.
I did a chat.
Only one minute has passed since I did this level.
Only one minute.
Don't listen to Nightbot.
Like, Nightbot's lying to you.
I'm improving my algor- algorithm.
I'm expanding my algorithm right now.
This is so sad.
There's a reason why we don't do variety.
The appropriate chamber for this testing sequence is currently unavailable.
It has been replaced with a nice fire core designed for military and droids.
All I think about is the big shot-quote.
What more can I say?
I know trigonometry, geometry in every tribe of three.
...for the inconvenience and wishes you the best of luck.
Okay.
Oh, it's the laser guys!
Can I move them?
Oh, I can move them!
Oh my god!
What do I do now?
Is this supposed to be like that?
Did I fuck it up?
Oh it's dead!
Okay, okay it's dead.
It's dead.
Oh my god.
Yeah it is, it's 1221 AM right now.
It's technically Wednesday right now.
What!
Stop!
Stop.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Stop, I'm safe.
I'm safe, I'm safe, I'm safe.
Oh I'm safe.
There you are.
Are you still there?
Yes.
Please shoot yourself.
Can it shoot itself?
Can this shoot itself?
Too bad, Kate.
Please.
I'm gonna trade on this geometry!
Oh no, now there's double the laser.
Now there's double the laser!
Wait, can it not shoot itself?
Can it not shoot itself?
Just dodge the bullets.
Wait.
What do I do?
I can just go behind him.
I can just go behind him!
I was trading on the geometry.
I can make it shoot itself!
I just went behind!
Oh my god.
Please!
Jungle!
Okay.
Hello.
Can I go behind here?
Oh shit.
Am I breaking...
Am I breaking the level?
Why did the music change?
What?
Am I supposed to be here?
Did I parkour?
Hey, Rally!
Oh wait, is this an easter egg?
I have no... What the fuck is this?
I have no...
What the fuck is this?
There's milk.
Can I use this to reflect people?
If I bring this out, would it shoot this instead?
I don't know.
Oh!
No, no!
That doesn't work!
Okay.
I never finish port...
Wait, where did I come from?
Oh, I came from here!
Okay.
Please.
Wait.
Can this block?
Oh!
This...
Wait, no.
Wait.
I thought this blocks...
Does this block?
Does this block me?
Oh, it blocks!
It blocks it!
Wait, wait, wait.
Please, please, please.
Oh, it does not block it.
It does not block this.
Me.
Wait, it can't even...
Please give it back to me.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
What do I do?
I'm bringing...
Am I bringing this over?
Okay.
Are you still there?
I'm just gonna rush.
Okay.
I'm rushing.
Oh, I did not bring this past me.
I didn't even bring this...
How do I get here?
Why did I bring this here?
Okay.
I'm just gonna rush.
What are they gonna do?
Shoot me?
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
No!
Wait!
How?
Oh, I broke it!
Yes!
Yeah, bitch!
I broke it.
That was planned.
I planned that.
Wait, do I get...
How much HP do I...
How much HP do I have?
Can I just keep breaking this?
I'm just gonna keep breaking these.
Fuck that.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no.
He heard me.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
What the fuck?
I didn't just break these!
Can you pick them up?
Oh my god, I didn't pick them up.
And then she dies from a dying turd.
Okay, okay.
All I have to do is just...
I'm sorry.
I should have tried to knock him over earlier.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, wait.
What if I use these?
What if I use these to knock them over?
Okay.
Oh shit!
No, please, please, please, please.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
And then I do this here.
Like this.
And then I'm gonna go break this one.
Okay.
And then I go...
And then...
This is how you do it!
Oh my god, I'm so smart!
I'm so smart!
Is this really how you do it?
Or am I just breaking the game?
Am I breaking the game right now?
This is actually...
Oh, this is actually...
Wait.
Oh!
Wait!
No!
Okay.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
You're not supposed to... Wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god, I'm so smart!
I'm so smart!
Holy shit!
Look at that shit!
Look at that!
Navajo collection of kids!
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking smart.
I don't need portals.
I don't need portals!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
I don't need portals!
Oh, wait, that's not... No, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't need portals!
This is such a back road!
Wait, is this not how you do it?
Is this how you play the game?
How else are you supposed to do this?
Wait, okay, okay.
How else am I supposed...
I wish I didn't do that.
Okay, wait.
Okay, I got...
Okay, let me like, geometry this real quick.
Alright.
So...
So, this is looking at this way.
Alright.
How do I do this?
There's no other ways to do it, that's why I...
I'll just... I'll do this.
This hasn't failed me.
This hasn't failed me, chat.
This has not yet failed me!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This has not failed me.
This has not fell...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm just regen HP.
No!
No, I didn't reach it!
I didn't reach it!
I was like, I'm just gonna die behind it.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you so much for the follow, Deluxon.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a... have a...
fun heart.
Thank you so much.
Wait, wait.
I just need another companion cube.
I just need another.
Chat says she can beat Portal.
Without Portals.
I don't need Portals!
Look at that!
This hasn't failed me yet!
No, no, no!
Okay, maybe...
Maybe it has...
failed me.
Maybe...
Maybe it has failed me, chat.
Maybe it has failed me.
But we can do this again.
Let me get rid of...
Let me get rid of this guy.
Boom, there we go.
Look at that.
And then...
And
then...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I just need one.
Okay, okay.
Searching.
Alright.
Okay.
No, please, please.
Please, okay.
All I need to do...
is just...
Do you have enough cubes?
Exactly!
Exactly, I just need a cube of walls.
This was my plan.
There you go.
Please, please.
Please.
Okay.
Okay, I have like 20 of these.
I have 20 of these.
There's no way I can fuck up.
There's no way I can fuck this up.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Thank you so much for the follow pass.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a fun, alright.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Why else would he give us 20 cubes?
There's no other way to solve this puzzle.
There's no other way to solve this.
I re...
I refuse to believe.
No way.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm regening HP.
Can't kill me if I'm regening HP.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's just giving me more cubes.
Okay, there's no other way.
I refuse to believe.
There is another way.
A fort of Dohki was established in response to the alarming that Braynation pre-properly would go an artificial life this way.
Can we please tell her?
Look at that.
Look at that!
He can't even see me!
Stupid!
I have three more!
He can't even see me.
Look at that shit.
Look at that.
Look at that!
Oh, he don't even know what he's doing.
He don't know where I am, huh?
Yeah, you fuck.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Yeah, he can't even get me!
One gas bitch!
Look at that!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, I'm not gonna bait them anymore.
I'm not gonna bait them anymore.
I still have two more.
Okay, this is it.
This is...
This is it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This hurts.
What do you mean, Jedrick?
This... Why else would they give me, like, two forts?
Seven queues?
They gave me seven queues, Jedrick.
What the fuck am I supposed to do with them?
Huh?
Build...
I'm supposed to build a fort!
What else?
Why push it like this?
Oh my god.
Please.
How do I get...
No!
Wait!
There's one here!
No!
My fort!
I spent so long...
making the fort!
No!
How was I supposed to know there was one more?
How was I...
Why are you shooting me?
Okay.
How am I gonna do it?
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm not gonna make the fort again.
But I still need these queues.
I still need these queues.
Okay.
Alright.
Geometry.
Okay.
Wait.
Let me...
This way is better.
Not this way.
Okay.
Alright.
What would you even do?
This is a game mechanic.
They gave us 20 queues for a reason, chat.
There is a reason why they gave us 20 queues.
Okay.
I'll never play the game so if I do, I'll play it like this.
There's a...
There's not a reason you're thinking that there is a reason.
Please.
Please, let me just...
Okay.
I'm trying... I'm thinking here.
I'm trying to think.
I made this fort for a reason.
Wait.
No.
Please.
Wait.
I have a fort.
Please.
I'm trying to think here.
I have a fort.
I need to think here.
Okay.
So...
Let me think.
Let me think here.
Here?
No.
Wait.
It's still looking at me.
Alright.
Thank you so much for stopping by.
I really do appreciate it.
I hope you get nice dress and good luck with work tomorrow.
Okay.
Uh...
Please.
What do I do with this fort?
Wait.
This is it.
Goodbye.
Wait.
No no no.
My fort.
No!
My fourth!
I got this.
I just need to slowly push this...
Okay.
I'm slowly...
That's right!
I don't know what it...
Oh!
Look at that!
Okay.
I got this.
I got... watch this.
Watch this.
And then...
Yeah!
Wait!
Okay.
Look at that!
That's a Q-Series for a reason!
That's a Q-Series.
Look at that!
Look at that shit!
I conquered the drones!
I did it!
I don't need no portal!
I have a... I have a fucking port!
Who the fuck needs port?
Look at that!
Look at... Oh, I need my cube.
I need my cube.
Wait.
How do I get rid of this?
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Wait.
I think I need portals here.
How do I get rid of this?
Oh...
I... I get it.
I see.
I need a...
Look at this.
Oh no.
Yeah!
I need no portal!
I didn't need a single portal!
Except for that one portal that I made.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Look at that shit!
I didn't need a single portal!
I didn't...
Is this what it means?
Zero-disc seed run incoming.
Look at that.
I can do that for the other one.
I didn't need a single portal!
Look at that shit.
See?
All I needed was a port of cubes.
I didn't...
You dropped it...
You dropped the cubes on the drone.
There was literally an X.
Wait.
What?
I didn't need to build a portal.
I didn't need to slowly push the cubes into the...
Yeah, but...
I had to see that chamber in this one.
Please take care of it.
My fort was too strong.
Fort... cubes together... strong.
There's little morphe on the ceiling.
Like a rip with the portal.
I don't need instructions!
Who do you think...
Who do you think you're talking to?
How the fuck do I get up here?
You think I need instructions?
I don't need that!
I make my own rules!
Look at that!
I make my own fucking rules!
I'm difficult but don't think I'm watching...
...Teeth Chat.
It's together strong!
Exactly!
I can just do this.
What's this gonna do?
Kill me?
The symptoms most commonly produced by enrichment center testing are superstition, Actually, Doki and Azuri can't roll.
Doki don't need to use a poem.
The enrichment center reminds you that the weighted companion cube will never threaten to stab you and, in fact, cannot speak.
...
I do not do that.
I, in fact, do not do that.
Thank you so much for the follow, Lmao.
Boys, thank you.
Have a...
Have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Hey, Zero.
Hey, now I'm dead.
I'm gonna take over setting Doki courses in heaven.
One of those bad boys.
Lookaboo the streamer.
This symptoms most commonly produced by enrichment center testing are superstition, Okay, okay.
...perceiving inanimate objects as alive.
What's this gonna do?
Kill me?
Oh, fuck.
The enrichment center reminds you that the weighted companion cube will never threaten to stab you and, in fact, cannot speak.
Okay, I thought I got the timing wrong.
I thought I got the timing right.
But I couldn't.
It did.
It did, in fact, kill me.
This symptoms most commonly produced by enrichment center testing are superstition, perceiving inanimate objects as alive, and hallucinations.
Let me time this.
The enrichment center reminds you that the weighted companion cube will never threaten to stab you and, in fact, cannot speak.
Okay, I just need crouch time.
Okay, okay.
Where is this?
Yeah.
Yeah!
Yeah, you thought you could kill me this time?
Ouch.
Yeah, you thought you could kill me?
I'm better than you.
I'm better.
Please don't.
Please.
Please, please, please, please.
Cube solve everything.
Cube solve.
Where is it?
Okay, that's the right way now, but still.
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
We gotta hit here.
Right?
Cube is meta now.
Wait.
Boom?
Oh, boom!
Oh my god.
I'm so smart.
Wait, my cube!
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Why?
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh, because there's this.
I was like, what?
Okay, where's the other cube?
Where do I get another cube?
Hello.
Where's the other cube?
Where must I acquire?
Where can I acquire?
A second cube.
What?
Oh, cube!
Cube.
Cube!
Wait.
Oh, okay, wait, wait.
Hahaha.
I was just at the other.
I'm not reinforcing this.
Again, I...
Hey, have you guys heard this new intro called Doki Doki?
I heard good things.
Oh my god.
Wait, where's the...
Where's the other one?
How do I get up there?
Oh!
Boom.
Oh, wait.
I fucked up there.
Ellie Eddy?
Hahaha.
Wait, what's this?
Wait, wait, I went backwards!
No, no!
I was here!
I think I already broke my mind.
I didn't realize I just went backwards.
Wait.
What do I get here?
No more booms.
I don't get booms.
I don't get
booms.
I don't get booms.
What?
Where do I get...
Hello?
These are nonexisting...
Oh, believe me.
Yeah.
It's already happening right now.
Right meow.
Wait.
Why is there a button here?
Where did you come from?
I know it.
As you don't know how to play it, like, don't you?
Oh!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
My brain.
My brain big, big.
My brain big.
Don't worry, chat.
Watch this, chat.
Watch this.
I get it.
I get it now.
Okay, I need to go back up.
I go here.
Yeah?
Yes, chat?
And then...
Uh...
There ain't no port of mass protection.
And then...
And then I go...
Hell, this game, if I had a port-o-gun, I would...
Okay, okay.
Bro, come over here.
Come on.
Bro.
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh!
Okay.
Um...
Yeah, that was... that wasn't it.
That was... that wasn't it.
That wasn't...
This is why I hate coming late.
Instead of that guy that she dead.
Okay.
I'm sorry that she found the best way to play.
Wait, does that do us again?
Wait, no.
I don't.
Oh!
Wait, never mind.
I thought you could go through here.
This game is not port and not cute for a reason.
Wait.
Wait!
Wait, chat.
I have a portal gun.
I have a portal gun, chat.
I know.
I know what to do now.
My brain expanding, chat.
Wait.
My brain.
My brain expanding.
Okay.
Alright.
My brain is not... wait.
You can put a portal there?
What?
Oh my god!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me double check if this works.
I need to make sure.
What the fuck?
What?
You can put a portal there?
Okay.
My brain expanding, chat.
And then I need it...
Where do I need this?
I need it here.
Alright.
Wait.
Where's my cube?
Holy shit.
I'm so fucking smart.
And then I put this here.
And then...
Wait.
Boom.
Yeah, that's right.
BOOM!
Woo!
Alright.
Look at that.
First try.
It's only been 30 minutes.
We've only been playing this game for 30 minutes.
And we're 90% done with this game already.
Is that crazy, chat?
Is that fucking crazy?
Do not trust Nightbot.
Nightbot is wrong.
Oh, I needed my cube.
I needed my cube.
Sometimes my genius scares me.
I know.
He said no.
Wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I've never...
No, no, no.
Only...
40 minutes has passed.
I mean 40 minutes have passed, chat.
Holy shit.
40 minutes have passed.
And we're already 90% done with this game.
Is that crazy?
Oh my god.
Help.
Thank you so much, Willful.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Have a boy heart.
Thank you.
Okay.
Well, you want me to burn this cube?
Yeah.
You think I care?
You think I give a fuck about this cube?
Yeah.
How do I burn it?
Excuse me?
I said all that?
I said all that and you're not gonna burn the cube?
Rest assured that an independent panel of ethicists has absolved the Enrichment Center, Aperture Science employees, and all the researchers of any more or less possibility for the companion cube, euthanizing process.
Oh my god.
Just burn it.
Please.
I don't care.
Yeah.
Oh wait.
Did I get burned?
What the fuck?
Did it burn me?
Why won't it burn the cube?
Oh.
Your companion cube cannot accompany you through the rest of the test.
If it could talk, Wait.
and the Enrichment Center takes this opportunity to remind you that it cannot.
It would tell you to go on without it.
Why wouldn't it burn the cube?
Because it would rather die in a fire than become a weapon.
Oh.
Yeah, you think I...
Oh!
What the... No!
No!
The Enrichment Center has your faithful companion cube more quickly than any test subject on record.
Congratulations.
Look, I thought...
I wasn't thinking.
Okay... Okay, I wasn't thinking.
I have to do this again!
Wait, what?
Oh!
I'm burning you twice now after that.
Yeah, you deserve to get burned twice.
Not this year, this again!
You know what?
Yeah, this deserves to get burned twice.
Okay.
Alright.
Are you- DUDE!
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
I'm just gonna put you here?
Putting you here.
Okay.
It's too big to hold.
I have to let it go.
Alright, alright.
Round two.
Round two of burning the cube.
Okay.
Alright, cube.
I already said my goodbyes.
Bye.
I don't give a fuck.
Do you think I care?
No remorse.
It killed me!
Why the fuck would I give a shit after that?
The experiment is nearing its conclusion.
Wait, there's instructions!
This requirement will remind you that you will be baked, and then there will be cake.
Now that you jumped in there, my dude.
Cube.
I thought, okay, to be honest, I thought the lava thingy, like, there was like an invisible wall.
So I wouldn't go down there and the cube would.
I didn't think when you jumped in with it, you'd die with it.
I thought it would just take the cube.
Okay.
Cube.
Hit.
Pit.
Top 10 anime betrayals.
Water bad.
Portal jump.
Portal drone.
Okay.
What's this?
Do I go here?
All employees must wash their hands.
Oh, wait, is there more here?
What's this point?
What?
What was the point of this?
Oh, no, no!
The experiment is nearing its conclusion.
The enrichment center is required to remind you that you will be baked and then there will be cake.
Okay.
Um.
Anyway.
This was first try.
Alright.
We just don't go over here anymore?
We just...
That never existed?
What?
Nothing happened?
Oh!
Oh my god!
I didn't know you could do that.
Where am I?
Rainbow chat?
Please look out more often.
No, I came from here.
Oh, there's...
Oh!
Wait.
Where am I?
Huh?
I...
Walk?
No, no, no, no...
No?
Walk?
What?
I can't...
Wait.
How do I get here?
Wait, where the fuck is the cube?
Huh?
Cube?
Oh, walk.
Walk.
Wait, no, I'm back here.
Wait.
Wait, I'm back...
Cube?
Cube-kun is dead?
What the fuck, how do I get this?
What?
Okay, there has to be a cube here somewhere.
Where is the cube?
Wait, wait.
Wait, where is the cube?
A box!
Box?
A walking cube.
I'm so confused.
I can't escape it.
I can't walk.
The cube has gotten my dude.
Why did you guys make me burn the cube?
I'm like, you're allowed to hit the cube, cat girl.
Where the fuck is the cube?
Is that here?
Cube?
What the fuck?
Wait, where do I go?
Okay, okay, we do this again.
Okay.
Okay, I don't know how I fucked that up.
WHAT?!
What the...
You guys saw that?
I'm looking for a money cube.
Like, no one ever saw you look so funny.
Thank you, cat girl.
Okay.
Cube.
Why is there a two here?
Two.
Three.
Cube.
How...
How did I get here?
I'm
so confused.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what color, what color was this?
Oh!
Ah!
I don't need no cube!
Wait, what's this?
Okay, what the fuck is this?
Make sure Dizzy doesn't make Doki putting her brain to the test.
Is she finally evolving some sproom brain-ness?
Hahaha.
Okay.
Oh!
No, no, no!
Dude, please, please, please, cube, cube, cube, cube.
Cube, cube, cube, cube, cube.
Cube.
Okay.
Hahaha.
There I go.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I have a butter.
Thank you so much.
No thoughts, only cube.
Where does this go?
What?
Wait, cube!
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, I need cube.
I need cube.
And...
Oh my god, wait.
Hahaha.
Wait.
How do you do...
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Portal.
I keep pressing this until I process this correctly.
Okay, so this goes...
Boom.
And then...
Wait.
Boom.
Okay.
It goes through here.
Oh!
What?
No, no, no.
Let me back.
Let me in.
Please.
No, no, no, no.
No!
Hahaha.
It...
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
I got this.
I just need to keep pressing this.
Okay.
And then I do this, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
They need to stop bombing once more.
Hahaha.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Please.
Does it reset?
Does this reset?
Oh my god, this resets!
What the fuck do we do here?
My question is about your art.
You drew a lot of dogs, but you can't draw cats?
Yeah, I've done lots of cats before too.
I've done lots of cats before too.
I've done a lot of cat emotes.
We just drew a lot of dogs.
In the past.
Past few commissions.
Also...
I'm trying to process this chat.
I...
I'm trying to process.
Raphael's cat doesn't raise a dog.
Where are you thinking?
Raphael's cat isn't despite it.
Ah!
She is angry!
Where are you thinking?
I'm guilty.
Raphael's cat doesn't take any actions.
Okay.
No, no, brain think.
Brain think.
I'm just trying to... okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Is this working?
Is it working?
Did it work?
What?
How?
Brain!
Brain updating to iOS 14.
I'm in here for five minutes and you're already on my favorite series?
What the fuck?
Your power is so entertaining.
Brain.
Brain think.
How?
Here?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, where did it go?
Please.
I don't understand.
There's too many things here.
Please.
There's way too many things here.
I can't process this.
Please.
Too many things.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
What if I destroy this?
Wait, is it destroying?
Is this...
Wait, did my game crash?
Oh, God.
Brain did it.
I did it.
I was so scared.
My game crashed.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait.
Brain did it?
Okay?
Oh.
Wait wait wait wait wait wait.
I understand.
Brain, I understand.
I understand now chat.
I understand it.
Okay.
I need to kill this.
I need to kill this so...
So this...
This needs to hit...
This needs to hit this right?
No!
Please!
Please please please.
Oh!
Please!
Wait wait wait wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Brain did it!
Brain... oh wait, how do I kill this?
Wait, how do I... how do brain kill this?
There is a good jump.
Brain going over, I tried to control both of the portals.
But we added cubes to the mix.
Okay, wait.
Chat, chat chat chat chat.
Chat chat chat, brain is going to do it.
No, no no no no.
No no no no no no no.
Wait, how do I kill this?
Wait.
Here?
Where the fuck is that?
Okay, where are you pointing at?
Where... oh!
Oh brain... oh.
Brain did it.
God, I'm so fucking smart.
It only took me one minute, chat.
I figured it out.
And all it took was one minute.
One minute.
Look at that, it's like a speed run.
It's like a speed run.
Okay, okay, look at that.
You can't refer to your own brain as a third person.
This is alarming.
At your game manager.
Okay, if I like... do I have to like keep clicking this or will it never...
will it like...
Okay, now I need to destroy... okay.
I need to keep clicking this or...
Okay.
Oh
my god, let me back in, let me back in.
I'm so scared.
Okay, I did it.
Oh my gosh.
No, no.
How do I...
Okay.
Do I need to like forever click this?
Or am I gonna be stuck?
I'm not braindead.
Do I need to always click this?
Or will I be stuck forever?
Will I be stuck forever if I don't click it?
Phone dying at 3% Alright, Siri.
Siri's taking five of us and watching my read.
Thank you so much.
I hope you...
God, I hope you have a good rest of the day.
This is what Twitter's like.
Getting lost in holes the moment you jump in.
It's a real porous cat me on my way to the stairs so we pay one.
It will inform it when it deletes.
Okay.
Alright, am I gonna be stuck here forever?
Am I gonna be...
Okay.
Brain thinking.
Brain think.
Oh, am I gonna be... Did I fuck up?
Wait, did I...
Did I fuck up?
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no, I did not fuck up.
It's here, it's here.
Brain here.
Okay.
What's over here?
Okay, nothing.
Okay.
Okay, brain think.
Wait, did I fuck up?
Chat, did I... How do I get back inside?
Wait.
Do I...
Chat, did I fuck up?
Am I supposed to...
not have it closed?
I don't know.
Oh, no, no, I didn't.
No, no, no.
No, I didn't fuck up.
No.
No, no, no, no.
Wait.
Brain.
Okay.
Brain?
Brain!
Okay.
Okay, I think I fucked up.
I think this needs to...
Brain no work.
Okay.
I got it, I got it.
I know, I know what to do.
I know.
I used the wrong portal.
I used the wrong one.
Brain sad.
I think I need to die again.
Right?
I don't know.
I just love getting really...
I'm doing the purple.
Brain purple.
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Brain.
Brain did it.
Yeah, you guys.
First try.
First fucking try.
No, no.
No.
Oh my god.
Are you...
No.
Okay.
Alright, I got it.
First try.
Bam.
There we go.
There.
You're keeping me up at four in the morning.
There we go.
Okay.
Cube.
We got our cube back.
Okay.
I'm gonna put this guy over here.
I'm gonna jump over here.
Wait, how do I press that?
Portal.
Huh?
Oh.
Portal.
Bam.
Look at that.
First fucking try.
What?
Oh.
First fucking try.
Huh?
Oh.
The brain's...
Okay, okay.
Is your brain on me?
It's not over till it's over.
What the fuck is this?
Portal.
Oh.
No.
Okay.
That was not the right portal.
Portal.
I'm so wide awake.
After just five minutes of joining in.
I'm having a stroke after that one.
Okay.
Look.
Oh, portal.
This one.
And then it's like, oh shit, I don't know why this...
I'm just playing sad.
Not sad.
I think I fucked up.
I fucked it up.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Oh, here, here, here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Portal.
No, no, no, no, no.
No!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Portal.
Huh?
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Get me out.
Okay.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Alright.
Got this.
Portal.
Wait, wait, wait.
We got this.
Portal.
Oh, I fucked it up.
I fucked it up.
I fucked it up still.
I needed to be high.
Wait.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Portal.
Blue.
Where?
Portal where?
Portal.
God, I'm a fucking caveman.
All I'm saying is portal.
In portal where?
Am I.
Hey.
Oh...
portal is trying.
All right, hold on.
They're strong.
Okay, I just remember not to use right click.
Portal.
Portal no.
Okay.
Okay, I just... okay.
Don't use... do not use left click.
Do not use left click.
Portal.
Portal to get it strong.
Who is the portal that you need on your way out?
Portal.
No, portal stay.
Ah-ha.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Don't use blue.
I know my colors.
Yeah!
Oh, well.
Look at that!
Look, she said well done!
She said well done.
The last sister got that.
Look, Kato thinks I did great!
I did amazing!
I got an A+.
I'm glad I was.
Portal strong.
Bunga bunga.
Portal round.
Welcome to the final test.
Oh my god.
Final test.
Portal good.
Okay.
The management center regulations require both hands to be empty before any...
Hit.
Aw.
Bad.
Wash hands.
Cake.
Okay.
So... Hit.
Fall.
Bad.
Okay.
Okay, this is bad.
Hit.
Wait.
Hit fall?
Hit fall.
Okay.
We're hit though.
We're hit.
Here?
Where does this go?
Hit.
What?
Wait.
Where this go?
Oh, here!
Okay.
Hit.
Wait.
It moved?
How did I get this to move?
Wait.
I somehow...
I don't even know how I got this one right.
Wait.
How did I activate this?
Oh, I...
Wait, I activated it.
Wait, how?
I didn't even activate this.
Wait.
Okay, I... I... I honestly don't know how I did that.
I... I...
I don't know how that worked.
I have the biggest brain.
I don't know how I did it.
So I just saw it unconsciously.
Alright, where's the...
Where's the thing?
I thought I saw your big brain there, but shit.
What?
Okay.
Brain.
Please.
Oh.
Oh!
Brain, brain!
Brain, big!
Oh.
Brain!
Okay.
Okay, brain mainly not big.
I'm loving you guys so much, I've been laughing.
Brain too big.
Brain gone.
No, no, no, not again!
No!
Okay.
Sorry, I... I got jump scared by...
by the thing.
Great.
What do I do here?
What do I do?
Brain?
Wait, what's this?
Wait, what?
Where am I?
At least you touched it.
Brain.
Here it is.
Wait.
What?
Oh, what?
I'm so confused.
I just keep going back to this thing.
I
just keep going back to this thing.
Brain?
Brain!
Congratulations.
The test is now over.
All Aperture technologies remain safely optically optional.
Up to 4,000 degrees.
Best assured that there is absolute I die?
I die?
Thank you for participating in this Aperture Science computer-aided enrichment activity.
What?
Oh...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
To be fair...
I...
Oh,
fuck!
Oh, dude.
I don't understand.
Where is it?
Where is the exit?
Oh!
It's right here.
I thought the exit was all the way back there.
That was police.
Alright, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Haha.
Look at that.
Green Big.
Please, let me out.
Look at that.
See?
Look at that!
This game only took me...
It only took me 30 minutes, chat.
Only took me 30 minutes.
I...
Oh my god, dude.
Thank you so much for the 100 bits.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Portal no.
Portal bad.
Open the door!
Wait.
Up?
No.
He's cheating.
Wait.
Huh?
Yeah.
I was learning about the zero in the last 30 minutes.
Look.
It helps me think, okay?
Less words helps me think.
This game is too big for me even to watch.
Apex 2.
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
I'm a caveman.
Yeah, that's right.
She's evolving just backwards.
Which way?
Left or right?
Does it matter?
Does it matter which way I go, chat?
Left, ooga booga, streamer, or right?
Wait.
All three?
Okay.
It doesn't matter.
She's still moving faster.
Oh.
Look at that.
Look at that!
Un-g- Oh.
I just moved.
Okay.
Where did I come from?
I came from here.
Okay.
I go in.
How goes the portals?
We're almost atlas.
We're advancing.
I'm advancing.
Imagine Doki playing as a desire.
Okay.
No.
Wait.
Where?
Here?
No.
Here.
No, no, no.
He...
Oh.
Up?
Up.
Wait.
This stream is looking good though.
This stream is gonna be pure go- Wait.
No.
Down.
Wait.
Where am I?
I- I was going up!
I was going over in time!
Up?
Where am I?
Wait.
Oh.
I gotta go up.
He cooked right- Down.
Oh.
Down.
Not- Not down.
Dead.
Oh.
Up.
Down.
Where?
Wait.
Oh.
Where do I go?
How do I get out of here?
You gotta die now?
Oh.
Not down.
She'll collect this race though.
Where the f- Okay.
Okay.
What's that?
Oh, they're the cubes!
She must have to leave because of- Okay.
Okay.
We have to go this door.
Here.
Okay.
Not that.
Clearly not that.
Oh!
Oh my god!
That's all I had to do?
Up!
It was up!
Pull the fridge out of kids- Up.
Down.
It was up.
It wasn't even a puzzle.
Oh shit.
It's the PS5 chat.
Look at that.
The PS5.
Look at here.
Okay.
No, I left but I'm back now.
The sheets they wave all the time.
Okay.
Alright.
Do I break this?
What do I do?
Wait.
Up?
No.
No up.
Oh wait.
Door.
Okay.
Door?
Break?
Do I do a toddlers thing?
I don't know what I'm doing.
Chained.
Now down.
Am I stuck?
I'm stuck.
Where do I go?
I opened all the doors.
What does he want me to do?
You seem a bit odd tonight.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Sorry my brain.
I'm trying.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Okay.
I went through two doors.
Oh.
Wait.
Where's door for this?
Where's the door for this?
Oh.
There's...
There's another way.
There's the other way.
Okay.
But it's been so long trying to open this door.
I thought we had to go this way.
I hear some of all that thinking.
Does this feel like Tokio's easel?
Oh.
Hey, don't give me brick hole.
Okay.
Where are we?
Alright.
Hole.
Also, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I love butthurt.
Thank you so much.
Your brain has overclocked too much already.
And it's starting to circulate.
So, I think...
That some of the room are all story.
Dude, I can barely fucking...
I can barely process.
I can barely process what's going on right now.
Let alone the story.
I can barely process shit.
Let's see how much I can push here.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, girl McAfish, what?
No!
Oh, cool.
Oh!
Down!
Down, Pog!
Is Andrew Brookey the Beatrix, or is he?
We're right!
It's down!
Oh, shit!
Hey.
Did he really just enter Monkey Break Road up?
Down?
Where the fuck am I?
What?
Oh, down.
Okay, the test is over.
You win.
You're welcome.
But you have to remember your annex for your cake.
Wait.
It was a fun test, and we're all impressed at how much you won.
Okay, okay.
The test is over.
Come back.
Oh?
Oh!
Oh my god!
That was so cute!
You're literally one of the first muscles you ever did!
Look.
Look, I'm a mess right now.
I'm a mess.
I'm a fucking mess right now.
Door!
Oh!
Door, door, no, door.
Oh, oh!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No?
They're like watching what the...
Or it looks bad.
Like, here's Doobie turning.
My brain moved.
My brain moved fast.
My brain... brain moved...
Good job, Doobie!
Ruby!
Okay.
Where did I come from?
Wait, where did I come from?
Oh, here, here, here.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I move up.
Up.
Down.
Oh my god, Atlas!
Thank you for gifting a sub to Elsar!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it.
Woo!
Can we get some work nights also for Atlas for gifting a sub to Elsar?
Thank you so much!
Okay.
That's the most words I've ever spoken since I've...
since I started this game.
That is...
That is the most words I've spoken tonight, chat.
Wait.
How... how go up?
No.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh!
No, wait.
Wait.
Now we're just...
Oh, there he is!
He's...
Hello?
How?
Oh!
I'm so sorry!
Yes...
Oh, no.
No...
Dang, it's bringing...
look at that.
Look at that chat.
Wait.
As you go back, the joy of hearing things out.
Oh!
Wait, where do I go?
Oh my god, Sire!
Holy shit!
Sire!
Thank you so much for giving me five subs!
Oh my god!
Thank you, thank you!
Can we get some bright nights real quick for Sire?
Thank you, everyone!
Oh my god!
Thank you guys so much!
I really, I really appreciate you guys!
I don't... Thank you guys!
My brain is going 200 miles per hour right now.
Thank you so much!
For... for...
For enabling my brain!
Thank you, Sire!
Wait...
Hello?
Wait, just A's on the brain... Wait, here?
Here?
Where?
I'm gonna go for the night.
That was nice of you.
Don't bring your brain out!
Alright, Alice!
Thanks for hanging out with us!
Thank you!
I really do appreciate it!
Door?
No, no door.
Portal?
No portal.
Ruby!
Thank you for the one bit!
Thank you!
Oh my god, Sire!
Another five gives and subs!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
I really do...
Can we get some...
And... and look like they keep on continuing to give subs!
From Sire!
Thank you, guys!
Can we get some breakdice?
Real quick!
For Sire, too!
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Brain... brain go brr!
Right here.
Wait, where did I come from?
Huh?
Oh, here!
Here.
Yeah!
Like, last nuts cup!
Oh my god!
Ruby!
Thank you for the 500 bits!
Holy shit, guys!
Thank you!
Are we, like, nearing the end?
Oh my gosh!
Look at it!
The cake is alive!
There it is!
He set the thing!
Oh my god!
Another five gives and subs!
Holy shit, guys!
Oh my god!
Entity!
100 bits!
Thank you!
Thank you, chat!
And another one!
Oh my god!
Guys!
And Shijin also gifting a tier one!
You guys are amazing!
Holy shit!
The brain is...
It's okay!
I really appreciate all the support, guys!
Holy shit!
Look at all these gifted subs!
Can we get some more fork?
Nice for everyone!
Shijin!
And Lucklad and Sire for gifting more subs!
Thank you!
Holy shit!
You guys are crazy!
This is the most I've ever said!
These were the most words I've ever said in a minute chat!
I just want you guys to know that!
This is the most fucking words I've ever said in a minute!
Other than brain, portal...
What the fuck!
Holy...
Wait, I think we're 200 now!
Gifting Sire!
Sire again!
And then Furtwark!
Jesus, guys!
She has evolved!
She can use language now!
I can words!
Thank you!
Thank you, everyone!
Oh my god!
Ah!
Retro 2 the Prime!
Holy shit!
I think we have the spooky stream!
I think we got the spooky stream!
Galaxy Array!
She can word!
Word good!
Word word good!
I'm pretty sure!
I just needed to refresh!
Also!
Jpro, Monkey, and Fiercee!
Thank you so much for the follows!
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
Here's some blood hearts chat!
We have...
Okay, we're just gonna wave...
Where am I?
Oh!
Up?
No, not up!
Yay!
Give the subs do count!
They do!
Holy shit, guys!
Down?
No!
Not down!
Alright!
Like I said!
When we hit our sub goal!
Which was 200 subs!
I think we hit it!
So basically...
Blood!
Where am I?
So basically...
You guys choose...
Um...
You guys basically choose...
What spooky game I'm playing.
So I'm gonna make a poll.
It'll be in my Discord.
We're gonna vote in my Discord.
So you guys are not in my Discord yet.
It's !Discord to join it.
And we're gonna do a little poll there for you guys to choose...
Choose the...
The spooky game that I'll play.
And it's not gonna be just a one stream thing.
It'll be like...
Multiple streams.
Until either I finish it, or I say fuck you guys and stop playing!
Oh no thank you so much for the follow, Lido!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate... Jesus Christ!
How about butter?
I honestly didn't think variety stream...
People would like my variety stream.
Because this is the first time I've done a variety stream.
And I didn't think you guys would like...
Oh wait...
Up.
You see that?
I'm so happy you guys like my variety stream.
Because like...
I didn't know... I've never done a variety stream before.
And like...
I was so scared that people won't like it.
So I'm really happy that...
People are enjoying this.
And enjoying... joining my...
My big brain.
My ginormous brain.
Wait...
Up?
That's an incredible stream!
I'm really happy you guys are enjoying!
Brain...
Wait...
Okay...
Up...
Never tell yourself...
I'm glad you guys are having a good time!
Brain...
Working...
Oh my god!
We got a level 5 Holy Peoples!
What did you guys get?
Choo choo!
Okay...
How do I get up there?
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Wait...
Up?
No feet today.
No feet today chat.
Here?
We went back!
Okay...
Oh wait where's my portal?
Wait...
Oh!
Wait!
What color was it?
I don't remember!
What color was that portal chat?
Orange...
Oh...
I did it.
It was orange.
Did I do it?
Did I?
Okay...
Is this it?
Oh!
Wait...
And then I was all...
We pretend if we were going to murder you...
Wait...
Maybe we're still expanding...
Is anyone there?
Maybe if I...
Maybe...
Oh!
Up!
I can't...
Every time...
It's just up!
It's just up chat!
It's very slow!
It's just up!
Wait... where the fuck...
No!
It was not up.
I'm off to WB back later.
I hate CJ!
Let me have a good dinner!
I know we have a good dinner!
It wasn't up!
Okay...
Wait...
Up!
Okay, I need to time this.
I need to...
I need to time up.
I...
Oh!
Oh, I know, I know, I know, I know.
Up.
Well, on the upside, you know...
What?
Why?
I forgot to put the portal!
Okay...
Okay, okay, okay...
This is...
Okay, right, this is...
Okay...
Here we go.
There we go, okay.
I am facing it.
I am...
Yeah...
Please, please let me through.
No!
Wait, wait, no, no, no!
Wait, wait, how do I do this?
How do I...
How do I do this?
Okay...
What?
I am so confused!
Is it not...
Is it...
What?
How is this hard?
How?
Angles!
Okay, okay, geometry.
It is simple geometry.
It is geometry.
I got this.
It is just geometry, right?
It is just geometry.
Up.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, oh!
How am I fucking...
I am fucking up!
Up.
Oh, oh, oh!
I did it!
Sire!
Another two gifted subs to Turbinal!
And all!
Thank you, Sire!
Woo!
Can I get some more park nights?
Sire, thank you for the crazy support!
43 gifted subs!
Holy shit!
Sire, thank you so much!
I really, really do appreciate this.
Okay.
Thank you so much!
Okay, brain.
Brain.
Up!
Okay, okay, okay.
Haha!
Oh?
What?
Oh!
Wait.
Up.
Hahaha!
Oh, I am so smart!
Look at that.
Oh, never mind.
I am trapped here.
Hahaha!
I was like... I was so happy!
I was so...
Hahaha!
It's locked.
It's locked!
The door is locked!
And empty!
The door is locked.
Are you a zombie?
Hahaha!
No door!
Wait!
Where?
Hahaha!
Is this a thousand times funnier when drunk?
Where?
Up?
Oh!
Boom!
I can't aim!
Okay, okay, okay.
I got this.
I got this chat.
Boom!
Okay, okay, okay.
I got this.
Boom!
And then... Okay, okay, okay.
It's here.
Okay.
Wait.
Hahaha!
It's like this, right?
And then... Okay.
Wait.
It's right here.
It's like this, right?
And then...
Okay, okay, okay.
It's like this, right?
And then...
And it... Whoa!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Hahaha!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
It's...
It's like this, right?
And then...
Okay.
It's like this, right?
And then...
Okay.
It's like this, and then...
Wait.
Okay.
I just realized it's supposed to be here.
Okay, it's like this right?
And then... okay it's like this and then...
God!
Okay...
Okay, it's like this right?
And then... and then...
Okay, okay we got it.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, it's like this right?
We did it.
Yes, yes Doki.
Simple really.
Yes, it's like that.
It's like that.
It was like that, chat.
Okay, first try.
First try.
What?
How did?
Excuse me.
What the fuck?
I didn't...
You really did too close.
Yeah, I... yeah, yeah.
You guys... yeah, you're right.
I don't know about you.
I don't know what happened there.
Bro...
Rebacking.
He leaves.
He goes okay.
Why are there so many things here?
What... why are there so many?
Which one's the right one?
Okay,
okay, okay...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay!
Okay, okay!
Alright, alright, chill.
Chill, chill, chill.
One of them is the right one.
One of them will be the right one.
Okay, okay, okay, we're back here.
We're back here.
Okay, alright.
Nope, not yet.
Not yet.
Okay.
One of you guys will be the right one.
Wait, this is orange.
Orange.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
No.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No.
Where am I?
Wait!
No, no, no, no.
Up?
What?
Where?
How?
Wait.
Wait, did I fuck up?
No!
I fucked up!
Oh, wait, wait.
Am I in the right way?
Wait, where am I?
Okay, okay.
How did they work?
Okay.
We got this.
Yeah.
Where do I go?
Wait, do I actually go?
Oh, no, no, no.
Down.
Down?
Oh, we go down.
Oh, damn.
My BF just became a semi-Vtuber.
They grew up so fast!
They drew a wolfy!
Thank you so much for the tier 1 sub!
For five months!
You get some free nightzoo quick for wolfy?
Thank you so much for the fucking tier 1!
Thank you!
That's so cool though!
That's really cool!
Okay.
How do I?
How does one?
How?
Jump?
Jump here.
Oh!
No, don't jump!
Don't jump!
Oh my god.
Ruby, can we get some sub 2?
The park night!
Can we get some park nightzoo quick?
For Ruby.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
And also, thank you so much for the five bits!
Thank you, thank you guys!
Wait, where the fuck was I?
Okay.
We got this, we got this.
Brain upgrade!
Brain upgrade.
Here?
Here.
Alright, alright.
We gotta wait until this thing goes down.
And then... BAM!
Look at that.
First try.
No deaths.
Look at him bunny hopping right now.
I'm gonna get some roots, you guys.
Open?
No open.
Park night is a park night perfectly balanced as all things should be!
Oh my god.
Is this another rat?
Oh, this is like another...
The rat thingy.
Okay.
All we have to do...
Is go through here.
What?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait!
I don't have cubes!
Wait.
I don't have cubes.
Oh!
No!
No, no, no!
No, no, no, no!
No!
Okay, wait, I got this.
I got this.
I don't need cubes.
I don't need my cubes.
Okay, which one's the first one?
Is this the first one?
Yeah, you thought...
You thought you're better?
Yeah!
I don't need cubes!
Where's the second one?
I don't need cubes, are you serious?
I don't need cubes.
Wait, wait, where's the third one?
Where's the third one?
Wait.
Wait, I don't need...
I don't need cubes.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you hitting me?
Oh!
No!
That's how you do it.
It keeps over portal guns.
That's how you do it, chat.
That's how you kill a lot...
You don't need portals.
Also, thank you so much for the follow-up.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Have a butter.
Thank you.
You don't need portals.
Okay, how do I get out of here though?
Oh.
Am I stuck?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, I got stuck there.
Ha.
Stop.
Oh!
Okay, not up.
Not up.
Okay, it was not up.
Oh.
Where's up?
Oh, oh.
It is up.
We're up.
Hey, Cypher.
Up where?
Up is up.
But where?
We're up.
We're like square.
But I just walked into.
Look up.
Okay.
Okay, one of these will hit.
Up?
At the grabber.
There was a sign?
Caution.
Oh!
Up!
Wait.
Up?
Up!
Up.
You're not making a person.
You know that, right?
Good people.
Don't get up here.
Can you hear me?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, imagine you're seeing this out of context.
Okay.
Oh no.
Wait.
Okay.
There is no goddess.
I'm here.
Okay.
Clearly I don't know how to jump either.
Alright.
I came here out of context and was lost as fuck.
I used the portal.
Ha ha ha.
This is the first time I used a portal for these guys.
I'm gonna be like.
Here.
Thank you.
This is the first time we use a fucking portal for these things.
This is the first time we use portal for these things.
Cause we have no...
We don't have a cube.
We don't have cube.
No cube.
What the fuck?
Oh...
No cube.
We actually have to... over here...
Oh my god, there's instructions.
There's instructions.
What?
Okay, that was not a good instruction.
Oh wait, is he pointing up?
Is he...
Improvise, adapt, overcome.
Oh!
Oh, he was pointing at this!
I was like...
Up, or forward.
I thought he was talking about forward.
I was like, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
Matt, you guys make me laugh.
Am I because of the alcohol in the house?
You still make me laugh.
GG with the portal.
Oh, good luck with the portal.
Thank you, Phoenix.
Okay, up.
Oh!
Oh...
Oh?
Oh!
Okay, it's blue.
Okay, remember to use orange.
Okay,
wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, wait.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Yeah!
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
We got this.
Wait.
Guys!
Fucking first try.
All we had to do was wait.
Look at that.
We waited.
This is your fault.
It didn't have to be like this.
I can open doors.
Please try.
Turn back.
Holy shit.
It...
Whoa, my God, we only been playing this game for 50 minutes.
We've only played this game for 50 minutes.
We're gonna die.
And we're almost finished with this game.
Isn't that crazy, chat?
Only 50 minutes.
Yeah, don't trust Nightbot.
Nightbot's being weird right now.
There's like a bug right now with Nightbot.
But it's only been 50 minutes.
What's that?
No, 50.
Hi.
Oh!
Let me out.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
I didn't know.
Yeah, it's only been 50 minutes, chat.
Okay.
Over here.
Over here?
Missile?
Portal!
Portal.
Yeah!
You see that?
Portal!
Okay.
Portal.
Do you see that?
Is that a portal again?
Okay.
What's a portal?
Never heard of it.
I'm generally concerned for you.
What do you mean?
I'm trying my hardest.
Portal?
Cube?
Cube...
Wait.
Cube.
We got it.
We got cube.
Okay.
We don't need this.
Like is it okay for you to be out in society in this state?
Look.
It's just portal.
Portal...
Portal did this to me.
Portal?
It's just portal.
This is why I should not be doing...
This is why I don't do puzzle games chat.
This is my brain on puzzles.
Okay.
Portal is just an excuse.
What do you mean?
I swear.
Oh my god.
Look how fat.
I'm speed-running.
I'm speed-running boys.
And girls.
I'm speed-running.
Oh my god.
That's so fast.
I'm speed-running.
I hate this.
This sound...
is disgusting.
This is disgusting.
Wait, am I supposed to portal?
Oh, I'm supposed to portal out here.
I'm supposed to portal out here.
Turret?
Wait.
What?
No.
No!
No tur- no!
I don't have my cube!
Wait, wait how do I do this?
Okay, now I have my portal.
Now I have my cubes.
Now I have my cubes chat.
Now I'll use this guy.
That's not... okay.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No!
Okay.
Okay, wait.
No!
Wait, wait, wait.
Can this block?
Okay.
Can I do this?
Look at that.
I'm so smart.
What are you doing?
I-I- This is my cube now.
This is my cube.
I'm just using them to knock the others over.
Okay.
Which one?
Who's next?
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
I used this right in short.
The scary laugh is looking... Okay.
It's looking different than I remember.
Okay.
No.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Please give me like five minutes.
Give me five minutes, drone.
Please.
Don't shoot me.
Okay.
There we go.
We got this.
We're very slowly.
I'm trying to kill a spider.
I'm just killing a spider real quick, chat.
I'm killing a spider with another spider.
Okay.
I don't know what happened but I'm having a good time.
How do you get there?
Oh, there's another ops here.
How many more spiders do we have left?
All right.
Two more.
How do we get up there though?
What do you mean?
They're dying, aren't they?
They're dying.
That's all it matters.
It doesn't matter how we do this as long as this is happening.
Oh, I messed up.
Okay.
No.
As long as this happens... NO!
NO!
Where did it go?
No, my spider!
Okay, it's okay, I have a backup.
I have a backup.
Wait,
I need another one.
I fucked up.
I need to get another one.
Where is the... I need to find another spider.
Okay.
We have a backup, backup.
Don't worry.
Okay, you know what?
I'm just... Okay, this is more easy.
This is easier.
Here we go.
Look at all... Look at all these... Look at all these turrets.
Okay, this is the new one.
Alright, where's the last one?
Last one's over there.
There you are.
Okay.
Target lost.
Look at the massacre.
Alright.
Alright, we got it.
We did it!
It's not... Oh, there's one more.
There's one more?!
Okay.
Which one's... Which one's the new one?
Oh, okay, that... We're not using that, I guess.
Okay.
Orange.
Alright.
Okay.
Look at that.
We did it.
Exterminate Doki.
Alright.
I'm gonna assume it's like this, right?
Where does this take me?
Oh!
Wait, what?
What?
I'm so confused.
Up.
Okay.
Up?
Up.
Oh!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
And then... Oh!
Up.
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
Okay, it's blue.
Blue.
Use blue.
And then... Blue!
And then... Okay, that's not it.
Okay, wait.
I...
Blue.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Blue.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got this chat.
I got this.
Don't worry.
My brain.
My brain going...
Blue?
Orange.
And then... Blue.
And then... Orange.
Orange, orange, orange, orange, orange.
And then...
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Blue.
Blue?
Wait.
Blue.
Orange.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Processing.
Orange.
Orange?
Yeah, zero deaths.
Zero deaths.
We've not died once.
We have not died not even once.
Not even once.
Orange.
Blue.
And then...
No!
Ah!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Orange.
Blue.
Okay.
How am I fucking this up?
Like, what is that?
Okay.
Orange.
Orange, you glad to see me?
Woo!
Okay.
Blue.
You died five times less just because I died zero, guys.
That means you have died zero.
Exactly.
Orange.
Blue.
And then...
Orange.
Blue.
And...
Oh.
Blue.
How do you fuck that up?
And...
And then...
Okay, no.
Okay, and then...
Yeah?
And then...
Okay.
You got this.
And then...
Okay.
No, no.
And then...
Wait!
Where the fuck am I?
Where did I go?
Wait!
Okay.
Okay, wait a second.
Okay, okay, okay..
okay It's gonna work, I swear.
Okay.
All right.
And then..
okay, okay, okay.
And.
Okay.
Wait, no, no, no.
This is it.
And then..
Okay, okay..
All right.
And then..
Okay..
This will work.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm just practicing.
This isn't the real... I'm just practicing.
I'm practicing.
And then... okay.
Alright.
It won't work, I swear.
Wait.
This is so... and then... Alright, alright, alright.
And then, okay.
Alright, and then... alright.
And then... alright, alright, alright.
Okay, I'm just practicing.
I'm just practicing, chat.
I'm just practicing.
Here we go.
Oh.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
And then... boom.
And then... No!
Not giving it.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm just practicing.
I'm just practicing, Chad.
Let's just practice.
We're gonna get it.
Boom!
And then... okay.
This wasn't it.
I'm practicing more.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Boom!
And then... Boom!
Oh my god!
I fucked it up again!
Okay.
Okay, when I get there... Okay.
Alright.
I'm just practicing, Chad.
I'm just practicing.
What the fuck?
How do I do this?
Okay.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
And orange, right?
No!
Oh!
Oh, blue!
Orange!
Wait, wait, wait!
I got it!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Orange.
And then...
Oh, blue.
And... Oh!
I told you, I was just practicing.
I was just practicing, guys.
Now I'm a pro.
Now I'm even better at...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I was just practicing.
Chad.
I had to practice my portal skills, you know?
Okay, how do I get out of here?
Look!
My FPS skills!
Look at me!
I'm head glitching!
My FPS skills led me to this!
And led me to Flix!
And head glitch!
Look at that!
Look at them Flix!
Look it up!
Up?
Okay, I fucked up up.
I fucked up up!
I somehow fucked up up, guys.
Okay, okay.
Oh!
Okay, let me need water.
I need water.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Can we do another up?
We can do another up.
Okay.
Alright, up.
And then...
Okay, maybe this is not the right portal for up.
That's why I'm black for a hand!
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it!
Have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Maybe I need...
Um... maybe...
Up here?
Up here.
Yes!
Up!
Up, up, up.
Okay.
Now down.
Down, down, down, down.
I always think when there's no game...
It's hot right now on YouTube, I guess.
You could just do old games.
Old classics.
Okay.
Wait, where did I come from?
Oh, I came from here.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, cause there's door.
Door.
Look, I'm bunny hopping.
I don't think this is actually bunny hopping.
But...
Okay.
Oh shit!
Is this GLaDOS?
GLaDOS, is this you?
Look, are you proud of me?
Are you proud of me, GLaDOS?
I did it!
I went up!
Wait, more missiles?
Wait, is this a boss fight?
Wait...
Oh no.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, is this Wheatley?
Who are you?
Are you Wheatley?
Wait, is this Wheatley?
Who are you?
Are you Wheatley?
Are you the blue guy?
Okay, but he's purple.
What am I taking?
Okay.
Alright, alright.
What do I do?
I don't want to tell you your business, but if it were me, I'd leave that thing alone.
Oh.
What's it?
Do you think I'm trying to trick you with reverse psychology?
Button!
Okay, fine.
Don't touch it.
Pick it up and just stop it for a minute.
Button, good.
Let's be honest.
Neither one of us knows what that thing does.
Oh, bird!
Just put it in the corner and I'll deal with it later.
Okay, now...
Nothing is probably some kind of raw sewage container.
Button, good.
Mortal yes.
Alright.
Button.
Maybe you should marry that thing since you love it so much.
Do you want to marry it?
Well, I won't let you.
How does that feel?
Oh.
Alright, button.
Button, good.
Have I lied to you?
I mean, in this room?
Trust me, leave that thing alone.
Alright, alright, alright.
Come on.
No!
Okay, I just need to line it up.
I am being serious now.
Okay.
That crazy thing is not part of any test.
Oh, bird!
Portal!
Okay.
Oh!
Button, good.
Then portal, good.
Portal.
And then...
Oh my gosh, I'm so smart.
I went...
I'm so smart.
Button, good.
And then portal, good.
And then bird, good.
There.
Oh my god.
I'm so...
Oh my god, I did it.
I did it.
It's negative right now.
It's a single person.
I figured out what that thing just incinerated.
It was a morality core they installed after I flooded the enrichment center with energy and toxin.
I'm back with one-hit-all-engine-bat.
Welcome back, Siri.
We're just doing the final...
final boss fight.
I thought they were...
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god, you...
Wait.
Button.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
How do I...
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah!
See now, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
What?
Hey.
Oh, I missed.
I missed.
I fucking missed.
Wait.
Where does this lead?
Wait, I missed again.
Damn, I missed.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Is this...
How do I keep missing?
Okay.
I'm just gonna go here.
Alright.
Is this...
Wait.
Where is she?
Where even is she?
Oh!
Oh, gas will kill me if I take too long?
Oh no.
Wait.
Is this... Is this her?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Is this it?
Yes, yes!
Yes, I lined it!
Geometry!
I did it!
Wait.
Button?
But... It's a spea... Spear?
Spear!
Oh!
What?
Wait.
Button!
Oh!
Wait!
Wait three minutes!
I got this!
Wait!
Wait.
Okay.
Blue.
There you go.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Button.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry, bro.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna press button.
No!
Don't you dare.
Okay.
Button!
Oh!
He fell.
Clearly!
I'm three minutes late!
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Please.
Okay.
Geometry, geometry.
Geometry.
Geometry, geometry, geometry.
I got this.
Look at this.
Look at this chat.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No!
No, no, no.
Don't move.
Yes!
Ball?
Wait.
Ball!
Two minutes!
Where's Ball?
Ball!
Where are you?
He's still something.
Burning.
Where's Ball?
Wait.
On top?
Oh!
Top.
Top, top, top.
Wait.
How do you get top?
How do we go up?
Up!
Two minutes!
Portal!
Up!
Up?
No.
Wrong up.
Portal!
Okay.
Orange.
I'm trying to figure this out.
.
Oh!
No!
Wait.
How much time do I have left?
Two minutes.
Two minutes!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, Okay, okay, okay Guys, I don't do well under pressure!
I don't do well under pressure guys!
Wait,
I fucked up... Wait, okay... One minute... One minute... One minute.
Okay, okay, okay, belts.
Up, up, up, up, up, up.
Up, up, up.
I don't do well.
I don't do well under pressure.
I DON'T DO WELL UNDER PRESSURE.
AH, NO!
WHERE IS ALL THIS.
NO!
Oh, for- oh.
40 seconds!
Please.
...
Please, do- Please.
Please.
Please, I don't want to do all this.
Please, please just die.
No!
Please, don't!
25 seconds!
No!
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Fall!
30 seconds!
Wait!
Where's Fall?
Fall, come down!
I don't... Fall, come down!
Fall!
I'm dead.
I'm so sad.
I'm fantastic.
Ok, Ok.
Ok, now I know.
Now I know, chat.
Now I know.
I can't f*** up now.
Wait I f***ed up.
Wait, I'm so... Wait, I f***ed up.
Ok, I can't f*** up now.
I can't f*** up now.
Rocket!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, I can't fuck up.
I can't fuck up now.
Okay, okay, I got this.
I got this memorized.
Okay.
Rocket, gay.
Okay, I can't fuck up.
Please, please.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, now I can't fuck up.
I can't fuck up now.
Please, please.
Please.
Orange, orange, orange.
Please, I can't fuck up.
I can't fuck up.
Wait, wait, I fucked up.
Wait, wait, how did I fuck up?
Wait, wait.
Okay, I can't fuck up.
Wait, I fucked up.
Wait, I can't fuck up.
I can't, I can't, okay.
Okay, I'm fucking up.
Okay, chat, I'm fucking up.
I'm fucking up right now.
I'm fucking up.
I was so excited thinking so shit thinking how am I fucking up?
How?
How am I fucking up?
Okay, okay, alright.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, guys, I'm pro- okay, there we go, there we go, I can't fuck up.
I can- what?
What?
How did- how?
How?
Please, please, please, how?
How am I fucking up?
I'm fucking up.
I'm fucking up, chat.
Okay, can't dodge this.
She can't dodge this.
Okay, okay, okay, blue!
Blue, orange!
No!
Oh!
Wait!
Blue!
Orange!
Wait!
Blue!
Orange!
orange, blue!
I can't fuck up!
I'm here.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I can't fuck up.
There's no way.
Okay, bye.
Alright.
Up, up, up, up.
Okay, two minutes, two minutes.
I have two minutes.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Blue.
Blue!
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
Blue, blue.
Hit me.
Orange.
Are you... Oh!
I can't fucking game!
Oh!
Under?
Wait, under works?
Under works.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
What?
No!
Under no work!
No, no, no.
I'm fucking up.
Wait, I'm fucking up.
I'm fucking up!
No, wait.
I'm fucking up.
Okay, I don't work under pressure.
Okay, don't work well under pressure.
I don't work well under pressure.
I don't work well into pressure.
Please, please.
HOW?!
How are you dodging this?
Please.
Please, please, please.
Shoot me.
Please.
Oooh.
Okay, WHAT?!
WHAT?!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, blue.
Blue.
Okay, okay.
Please.
Two minutes.
Please!
Please, please, please, I'm fucking up.
I'm not throwing.
I'm actually not throwing.
How is she dodging this?
She's dodging this.
This one I'm not fucking up.
She's dodging my fucking thing.
She's dodging it.
How?
How is she dodging this?
I have 46.
Please.
Okay.
Up.
Wait.
How do I do this?
I'm fucking up.
How?
Please.
How, chat?
How?
How am I...
Please!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
You can't do this!
No!
How?
Ok...
Ok, speedrun...
Ok, ok...
No dodge!
How are you dodging this?
Slow and steady.
Ok, ok...
How are you dodging this?
How the fuck are you dodging this?
I don't understand.
Thank you so much for the follow, boss.
Thank you so much for following, boss.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
How?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Slow and steady.
Slow and steady wins the race.
Okay.
Alright.
Slow and steady.
Slow and steady wins the race.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait.
Wait, maybe?
Unless...
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, this angle.
This angle, this angle, this angle.
This is good angle, right?
This is not good angle.
This?
Oh, this is good angle, right?
Oh.
Oh, this is good.
Oh, this is good angle.
This is good angle.
This is...
This is... Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, this is good angle.
This is such a disaster.
This is good angle.
This is it.
This is the one.
I fucking, I fucking give up.
I fucking give up.
We're just using this angle.
This is the angle that we're gonna use.
Here we go.
This is the angle.
This is... HOW ARE YOU DODGING THIS?!
HOW?!
HOW ARE YOU DODGING THIS?!
HOW ARE YOU DODGING... HOW?!
HOW?!
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Here we go.
Blue.
Okay.
Wait.
Over here.
Blue.
Where?
Okay.
Slow and steady.
We have three minutes.
What's the race?
Slow and steady.
When's the race?
Slow and... Where did he go?
Where did he... Where did... Wait!
Bro, he went in!
Where did he... Okay.
Okay.
Bro's like, where did he go?
Okay, okay.
He... He fucking... He felt bad for me.
He felt bad for me that he went in the portal.
Wow, the flight power.
He fucking dodged this.
Okay.
Two minutes.
Slow and steady.
Slow and... Oh, this is not angled right.
This is not angled right.
Whoa.
Wait.
I lied.
Slow and... Blue.
Purple.
Orange.
I got you!
Woo!
Oh!
Wait!
He thought.
Where are you?
Yes.
Yo.
This is it?
Can I do it?
What did I do?
Look at that.
First try.
Slow and steady.
We did it.
Zero deaths.
Oh.
Zero.
Zero deaths.
It only took us an hour to play and finish this game chat.
It only took us an hour.
Isn't that insane?
It only took my nightbot.
My nightbot is broken right now.
But it only took us an hour to finish Portal.
We're so gay.
It only took you an hour to beat you guys.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We drew a brawl record.
Oh my god.
Oh we did it.
We did it chat.
We're ready to join it.
Dude.
I'm a fucking mess right now.
I'm a fucking mess.
There it is.
There's the cake.
Oh there it is.
We did it.
Happy birthday.
I'm crying.
I actually have tears in my eyes.
I actually have tears in my eyes guys.
This took me so long.
This game took me so fucking long.
Oh my god.
I actually have tears running down right now.
My thirst's taking over your strength.
Oh my god.
I'm a fucking mess.
We did it.
We did it!
What if I came first shape just because I got it?
Oh no, Christy!
Tears of happiness!
No more up!
No more portal!
I showed up on the wrong time.
No more up!
I feel brighter now that I've surprised you.
I can't believe it only took you 10 minutes.
This took me... Chat, this only took me 15 minutes to beat this.
That's crazy!
First try, ew.
She's so worse than me.
Oh my god, I'm wiping tears right now.
Chat, my head tracker is wiping tears out of my eyes right now.
Oh my god...
We did it!
Oh my god, we did it!
My fucking... my fucking tracker's broken because I'm crying!
My model's broken because I'm crying tears of happiness right now.
Oh my god.
We did it!
Holy shit chat.
She didn't use the Ernie superior cube.
Oh my god I have to cry.
Oh my god now I have crying.
Where's my cry?
It's alive.
No Roy please.
Please.
I've been through so much.
I've been through so much guys.
I've been through so much chat.
We did it.
Oh.
Congratulations we did it.
Thank you.